hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm going
to be checking out the second trailer
for a Mission Impossible rogue nation
I'm very very very [ __ ] excited for
this I was listening to the song won't
back down by Eminem and I remembered
that it was from Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol when that song started
becoming really popular because it was
over the trailers and it just got me all
these images of ghost Protocol and I was
remembering how much I loved the last
two installments but you can skip past
this next part if you want to get
straight to the trailer I wanted to give
a shout-out up front not at the end of
the video this time but up front to a
man who I [ __ ] love Joey Fajardo Joey
Fajardo is one of the coolest
[ __ ] oh geez you'll ever meet if
you look at our banner on the YouTube
channel you will see that there is an
art design of myself and many of the
rejects from left to right it goes
Lauren gosh she's the Chinese one
Samantha Feld she's the blond one Brandi
she's like the tall brunette Veronica
she's the hottest one of all the girls
myself Jerri Sally who's the redhead
Alyssa and Dan who is uh I think he's a
closeted homosexual who's with Alyssa
and chelina Myers I know there's a few
rejects who are not on here
but that's okay one day they will get
updated don't you worry
but Joey you're awesome dude my
girlfriend would love to have you for
the night just saying just saying let's
get to the trailer uno dos tres
you have to get through 12 feet of
concrete and 70,000 gallons of
pressurized water without any metal no
oxygen tanks Benji stand by to receive
Ethan you ready
yeah yeah doctors at one point if you
have an open that hatch after two and a
half minutes we're both dead
whoa whoa you okay to drive me a min ago
you were dead
what are you talking about this is not
gonna end well
mr. chairman the time has come to
dissolve the IMF it's not just a rogue
organization it is a disgraced
shutting down the IMF is a mistake you
may regret yeah Brent go sandy [ __ ] is
real do they know who you are
rogue nation trained joke we killed 90
IMF
they're coming after us with everything
you guys gave me a dumb scene man
oh [ __ ] boy you want to bring down the
syndicate it's impossible good position
I have I ensure is about to start get it
even the king will answer for every want
an act of Nathan you are responsible for
now we are all wanted by the CIA awesome
several real this may be our last
mission
let's make a count
for that door right now
yeah [ __ ] hate Heights and that is
just terrifying ah yeah that's not
talking about 100 I check this out again
hold on Oh
let's check so again you have to get
through 12 feet of concrete and 70,000
gallons of pressurized water without any
metal I love how their keeper is keeping
that leg stem really strong smile amine
group
the important point if you have an open
that hatch after two and a half minutes
we're both dead
I kind of wish the trailer didn't show
this scene even though school because
that would have been very intense
watching it for the first time you here
to drive me a min ago you were dead
what are you talking about this is not
gonna win well I feel like they're gonna
give Simon hey go long
mr. chairman the time has come to
dissolve the and alex parven I'm so
stoked these in this mess not just a
rogue organization it is a disgraced one
it's good be afraid
shutting down the IMF as a mistake you
may regret it's actually cooler that
Jeremy Renner's are this because the
more famous that's Brett go ascend if it
is real and they know who you are
so he's a great captures each trying to
we killed a 90 IMF
they're coming after this scene I'm
[ __ ] somehow a living a great one
stunts look legit Nancy you want to
bring down the syndicate it's impossible
good position I have I ensure is about
to start good king will answer for every
want and that of Nathan you are
responsible for the most fun trailer
they've had so far sure they've been
pretty serious
that this the car looks real I don't
believe they're actually in the car but
that looks legit this may be our last
mission to make a count as awesome as
this seems going to be I wish they shot
up an IMAX cameras
protocol
ya know I'm stoked for this film I
really am you know watching this a
second time and realizing just how real
the action sequences looked like it
didn't look like CGI it got me thinking
about Jack Reacher again because I know
it's the same director and even though
Jack Reacher wasn't like their greatest
film I still like the fact that with the
action sequences especially with the car
chase that I'm filming phone especially
with the car chase that it looked super
real cuz it was real it wasn't like CGI
doubt I'm excited to see them do that
with the stunts here because it looks
like they're honoring the same level the
same height of the impossible series
like especially honoring just how big
Ghost Protocol took it to because I know
that Tom Cruise tends to do the big
stunts taking ghost Protocol as
character characters were a little bit
like cartoonish you know and I don't say
the portrayals but that like they could
have died many times from certain falls
they took basically and I'm sure some of
that ridiculousness is going to be in
here too but what I'm really excited for
is that phone it's Jerry oh hey Jerry
what I'm really excited for is the is
the Sun sequences and Tom Cruise is this
looks [ __ ] awesome it looks like a
good hybrid of part three and four to me
where part three was really serious and
dark and Ghost Protocol was this awesome
fun spy adventure and I feel like
they're taking both elements and putting
that together anyway guys thanks for
telling me that was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter or we're
if we get enough followers we can get
product placement for things as toys to
shut that kid up outside
who's the next shoutout who's the next
shoutout
dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt dawn fruit
RAL hey I love watching your reactions
to some of my favorite movies you should
check out my youtube channel because I'm
a youtuber as well I'm also extremely
excited for the new Jurassic world movie
it looks epic
we'll talk to you later I think your
videos are totally funny and amazing lol
man that kid I swear I've never murdered
a kid before but I might might if I look
and look I feel like if I see the face
of that kid outside I'm more likely to
attract murdering the kids so I don't
look at the kids but damn that kid needs
that someone needs to slap that baby dog
for trial this is your shoutout not that
baby shoutout you look like what do you
look like Don you look young so I'm
gonna give you some um you know fatherly
advice here when you're young it's best
to start watching the most graphic
pornography you can because the more
extreme it is the more your sexual
satisfaction level will need to be so
you'll be pretty freaky in bed and all
women love that level of extremist all
of them yep